- Speaking of lawyers
being sanctioned in court,
we have a small update in
one of the Kraken lawsuits
in Michigan.
In the King V. Whitmer suit in Michigan,
U.S. District Judge Parker
has a word for the attorneys.
Specifically an order that states,
each attorney whose name
appears on any of Plaintiff's
pleadings or briefs shall be present
at the motion hearing
set for July 6th, 2021.
And that hearing specifically
relates to three different
requests for sanctions
against Sidney Powell
and the whole Kraken team.
And that's an order from a
judge that is not a happy judge.
That is not an order that says,
everyone is going to get out fine.
Now, we'll see what actually happens.
Even when sanctions are issued,
often they're slaps on the wrist,
but this is not a happy judge.
And we will see everyone
whose name appears
on any of plaintiff's briefs in court.